you know what Kerry was telling me the
guys were down in the Bahamas some of
the guys who work here Oh somebody who
got married and I told you that Gary
said he was in the room next to Ronnie
and he overheard Ronnie oh you're
kidding we get to the hotel right we
literally just got off the plane 4:30 in
the afternoon Barry now we got to be
somewhere right so we take a shower
we're gonna go down we're gonna party so
we're gonna go down there he goes I
thought this was a 21 and over hotel I
go it is she said I hear a baby crying
so I go I go watch because I hear like a
loud baby crying I start to listen and I
realize it's it's two people having sex
oh my god in the last she thought it was
a baby it was like a murder we're on a
long time oh my god like I walked up so
I go Mary its people having sex so we
put her ear to the door cheapish yeah
that's what it is yeah so so I go how
funny would it be if that's right
we go to this party I go Ronnie what
floor you on he goes sixteen I got one
roomie in he goes 831 I just look at him
I go I'm an 8 32 and he looks at me and
just starts laughing he knows he knows
and I go dude what's going on yeah we
got drunk at the pool and it was [ __ ]
crazy didn't sort of rest at a time
really I was putting pillows over a face
all the time
I mean you 60 [ __ ] 9 years old you're
out to 1:30 in the morning you're
[ __ ] she's screaming have you ever
heard sounds like that come oh that's
his donor I was murdering her with my
[ __ ] make you feel less manly in front
of Mary it made me it baby appreciate
Ronnie on a whole other [ __ ] level as
soon as he said to me what room are you
and I knew what he was story say why do
you why are you asking you not to
laughing I was in the loud [ __ ] suite
women really screamed during sex
sometimes
wow so that was in the afternoon that
night we all got back to our room they
got back by five minutes after us out of
heard Ronnie banging on the wall
oh my god I mean you got a respect right
cuz Ron Joyce thanks talking how he's a
sex expert but I guess you heard the
proof did she happen to squirt that
night possibly
I brought a raincoat
Robin has anyone ever made you scream
like that I mean you sound like a baby
crying I never hurt anybody
every baby right I think Mary just heard
it too much whatever it was she said I
think I hear a baby cry was Teddy
[ __ ] her with a pineapple
Ronnie's all sexed up he really is you
now people are masters that like what
they like ours it really has like he
really has mastered it he's a professor
of [ __ ]
I try